Chuck yes I'm gonna spend ten minutes on
one of the most important concepts in
all of civilization oh my God we're
finally gonna have the sex talk sit down
yes surface area okay nobody ever thinks
about it but no you know there's a
reason not because there would be a
reason it influences everything
everything I know okay
no everything I'm not feeling it I'm not
feeling this yeah why aren't you not
feeling it I'm not feeling surface area
as like sexy science I want to talk
about talk about gloves versus mittens
okay
all right which is warmer immittance
because my hands raised because there's
less surface area to radiate into space
really yes if you put your fingers in
separate things they increase your
surface area to radiate gotcha that's it
okay right all right okay
why mittens are warmer than gloves yeah
but you you lose them both at the same
rate yeah unless you're clip to your
sleeve and a quite for that you do that
with mittens not with regular so so when
we speak of gloves being warm where I
like it being warm right it's the
blanket it's the same temperature of the
air what's actually happening is you
want something that prevents your heat
from escaping right okay so you put a
quart of warm glove if it's a mitten you
will radiate heat from one part of your
skin to the other right in and so you're
not losing it right the only part that
can radiate is the outer surface to the
glove and the glove to what's outside of
that mm-hmm
okay excess that less surface area that
a full-up 5-finger glove except
unfortunately with mittens you have to
do this if you ever want to do anything
with these you got to take it off that's
the only problem I'm talking about
surface that's right we were talking
about Rob's are men you got
in the snow and you I gotta I gotta type
something yes even making a snowball
sucks with mittens anyway going let's
keep going surface area let's keep going
so you got me on the mittens in the
gloves what else is okay okay go ahead
you want more more okay that makes me
that depth because you said this is the
most significant thing in science and so
far we got gloves and mittens all right
oh you want more I need more how do you
make a pizza cool faster oh that's a
good question oh you cut it cut it
right okay when you cut it I was gonna
say you blow on it but then again we do
that you add at me when I do that okay
so you cut it so what you've done is
pizza as one big flat sheet you cut it
you're exposing surface area that it
didn't previously have cooler air and
here's radiate to the air okay okay
alright that's what I'm saying well
we're getting better now that's we're
talking about pieces what happens when
you are cold hmm
I don't under the coverage I don't care
where you are do you spread out like
this increasing your surface area that's
so funny when you said you were cold I
instinctively like this what you did was
you reduced the surface area of you in
exposure to the air around you reduce
the surface area okay and that's what
birds do if you look at pigeons your
hometown might have a different fauna
right pigeons watch them when it's
called out they sit and they puff up in
a big spherical ball yes they do and so
this is now if it's hot and you wanna
cool down what it what did your cat do
at home yes increase the surface area to
increase the rate your ability to
radiate out into space I just thought my
cat was a pervert do an expose
themselves written away and seriously do
you have to lick it in front of me I
mean come on
but go ahead all right but wait there's
more all right all right why is it why
there are hundreds of pastas oh they
each have different surface area that's
well but I thought that was to hold on
to sauce of course the sauce attaches to
surface area so in this in this scenario
the sauce is the heat so the sauce is
being held on by the what so yeah it's
whatever it
you want to communicate with right you
increase the surface area and that's
where your math and that's what you're
doing okay all right okay all right okay
have you seen the surface of your tongue
is it completely smooth not at all no
it's got texture however it was smooth
for at one point I looked an iron and
yet that will just flat me out with it
but when you want the labor molecules to
get in you want to have the textured and
this other word texted your tongue the
more taste you probably correct correct
so surface area is a part of everything
it is everything okay everything and so
if you want pasta to have the most sauce
stuck to it get the pasta it has the
most surface area for the amount of
volume the pasta represents okay okay
there you go I'm no longer in spaghetti
I'm that's boring now now there's a yeah
so you get like the fusilli which has a
lot of twists and turn that that out
that'll do it you know what we should
actually we should do the experiment one
day what's that but cross experiment
we'll do that which one has the most
surface area to the Lord or sauce or
which one tastes best oh right because
it's holding all the sauce
gotcha there you go same just got to let
you know I'm gluten free so I go in for
you before they lay down asphalt again
yes what do they do to the road below
they rip it up not rip it up but they
bump it up they bump it up at bumper
they make it really really rough they
squirt Jeff so that when they put the
asphalt on it there's more surface area
grab one connect nice God's Hill that's
what that's about
okay all right it's all about service
area superheroes everywhere I'm warming
up to surface area so Chuck what matters
is not only surface area but the surface
area relative to the volume that it's
enclosing okay okay that's really what
matters here because usually something
in that volume is trying to get out
mm-hmm all right and so so for example
if I have a like a
a cube there's a surface area it's got
six sides exactly I cut it in half do
two more sides it's the same cube right
but now I've exposed two extra sides to
it right I cut it again do it again okay
now watch if did you freeze butter not
them some people do all right okay if
you take take butter out of the freezer
my mom used to freeze butter because she
bakes do you know how to bring it to
room temperature
practically instantly I'm gonna say
grandma how grandma would have done it
no you take the frozen stick of butter
and you grate it ah you can't grate it
because it's solid and rigid but what
have you done to the surface area and we
added more surfaces and exposed to the
atmosphere job radiates to absorb the
absorb the heat do that now you're
finally getting me with this damn
surface area it's very at um mmm oh my
god I just thought about myself well I
love scotch and I don't like putting ice
in my scotch because you don't want to
water down very good scotch when you're
drinking it so they make these big balls
make ice cubes and the reason it reduces
the surface area bro I got one more if
your only job is to stockpile sunlight
into chemical energy then the only thing
you care about is surface area facing
the Sun right so now who in this world
has perfected that plants trees trees
trees
oh and of tropical plants like the giant
leaf okay forget the leaf not now
now how thick is the leaf nothing at all
yes very wide not something not so thick
that's a very high surface area relative
to the volume of the leaf it is a
maximum Sun eating machine nice it is
all about the surface area take that
sunlight
okay now way
min-soo for breakfast now in the rain
forest go ahead no shortage of water but
where there is a shortage of water and
there's no shortage of sunlight
you don't want high surface area because
you'll evaporate water out of your
surface area so desert plants dense junk
little chunky you ever seen see desert
cacti chunky and one walk around that
what they have done is reduce the
surface area relative to their volume
they're the Danny DeVito of putz
yes now a noisy damage I would think of
surface area to volume ratio so Chuck
you good with surface area I am
definitely good with surface area boom
thank you that was kneelin Chuck just
chew and fat on some of the physics that
thrives around us whether or not you
knew it that's right
start off keep looking
you